[ZH] 今天是很久的,希望你們都學會了很多
[ZH] 我們已經有很多的地方了
[ZH] 謝謝大家留下來參加最後一場分享
[ZH] 我們今天已經探討了很豐富的內容
[ZH] 前面我們說了醫療技術
[ZH] 我們先知道為什麼小孩在抗爭執,我們先去改變
[ZH] 我們先說瞭解決方法
[ZH] 而是一種方式的反應,當一個年輕人未能接觸技術,我們知道他們已經有了
[ZH] 兩種的談論是一種詳細的問題
[ZH] 我們如何能幫助困難的年輕人成為一個活動的年輕人
[ZH] 今天稍早探討的模式是卓越食物以及processing approach
[ZH] 就是梳理歷程的這個模式
[ZH] 其實這兩場演講的核心都在探討一個根本的問題
[ZH] 就是我們如何陪伴一個掙扎的青少年
[ZH] 幫助他成長成為一個
[EN*]  My final presentation brings those two conversations together.
[EN*]  Understanding tells us why a young person is struggling.
[EN*]  Teaching gives new skills, but neither of those by itself tells us how to respond in the actual moment.
[EN*]  When a young person is standing in front of us, and we have seconds, not minutes, to decide what to do.
[EN*]  There's a third piece, and it is the piece that I want to spend the remaining time on.
[EN*]  That piece is influence.
[ZH] 生活適應技能的一個契機
[ZH] 那因為光有這兩者
[ZH] 沒有辦法直接讓我們明白
[ZH] 在衝突真的發生的當下
[ZH] 要怎麼樣即時去應對
[ZH] 那特別是孩子站在我們眼前
[ZH] 然後可能在大發脾氣的時候
[ZH] 我們只有幾秒鐘就要決定要怎麼去反應
[ZH] 現在這個群組我經常開的群組
[ZH] 通常花了約三小時
[ZH] 所以我會嘗試做30分鐘
[ZH] 我通常要三小時才有關注他解釋完這個圖了,但是我先走三十分鐘所以我會禁止。
[ZH] 這就是《影響力金字塔》,《影響力金字塔》,《影響力金字塔》,《影響力金字塔》,《影響力金字塔》。
[ZH] 就是大家的講義上面,我們Tilos有建立這套架構的
[ZH] 那它的概念是在呈現不同的生理身心狀態的時候
[ZH] 那我們需要採取完全不同的應對層級
[ZH] 那這個金字塔有六個層級,最底層的,最大格的那個是基礎
[ZH] 然後一路向上延伸到頂端最小的層級
[ZH] 請大家看到圖的右邊有一個箭頭
[ZH] 下面是LOG,是身心狀態平靜的時候,上面的HIGH是具有很急性的痛苦,
[ZH] 所以往金字塔越上方移動,其實我們應對的方式就是越命令型的,
[ZH] 但是它在日常生活中應該要比較少被使用到,那接下來我就會從底層一路介紹到底層。
[ZH] 我們的團隊每天都在和年輕人面對面工作。
[ZH] 這些青少年可能有自閉症、互動症或是其他神經都讓特質
[ZH] 那我今天就希望讓大家走的時候是帶著三大訊息的要點
[ZH] 第二、第六極端是為了影響之極的影響
[ZH] 而是我們每一人都要問的
[ZH] 對不起,我們對不同行為的回應
[ZH] 為什麼需要根據青少年的神經系統或他的情緒狀態去靈活調整
[ZH] 第二個是,金字塔裡的六大成績分別是甚麼?
[ZH] 第三個是,當下只有幾秒鐘,你要怎樣迅速地在金字塔裡面選擇對的成績去回應眼前的孩子?
[ZH] 我猜我一開始有一個問題,我猜每個人在這個房間都會進入。
[ZH] 很多行動計劃都承認不一定是正確的,
[ZH] 那一個靜靜的心靈是永遠的地方在我們身上的地方。
[ZH] 在小孩的感受,或是在暫停,那一個心靈的心靈可以暫停地離開。
[ZH] 它無論如何明顯你所指定的規定,或是如何實現的效果。
[ZH] 那我先從一個大家都遇過的一個很困難的狀況談起
[ZH] 就是很多數我們在制定傳統計畫的時候
[ZH] 我們都會假設這個孩子他當時是冷靜的
[ZH] 他是可以講理的
[ZH] 然而當就是神經動作性的青少年或是孩子
[ZH] 他處於一個感官情緒超載或是一個關機狀態的時候
[ZH] 那個負責處理理性思考的大腦區塊會暫時斷線
[ZH] I think of a student I worked with a few years ago,
[ZH] bright, intelligent, confident, IQ in the 140s,
[EN]  The same tone, regardless of what state he was actually in, it rarely worked, and looking back I understand why.
[ZH] 它要求一個已經失調的神經系統去做一個平常它要平靜、平衡的時候才能做到的事情
[EN]  What actually works is different. Reading the physiological state first, matching our response to the level of distress in front of us.
[ZH] 比如說我們會在孩子崩潰的時候跟他們講道理
[ZH] 那就是沒有用的
[ZH] 那或是說當他們在出現故作行為的時候
[ZH] 我們把他當作是他在挑釁然後對他們更兇
[ZH] 那其實真正有效的方法應該是
[ZH] 我們要先辨識他現在這個當下的身敵
[ZH] 然後再將我們的回應配對到他們眼前的這個狀態
[EN]  That observation points to the core idea underneath everything I'll show you today.
[EN]  A regulated nervous system can listen, reflect and choose.
[EN]  A dysregulated nervous system is doing something else entirely.
[EN]  It is focused on survival.
[EN]  So our job is not to master one technique and use it with every adolescent in every moment.
[EN]  Our job is to recognize which state we are looking at, regulate, rising or activated, and respond accordingly.
[EN]  That single idea is the engine behind the framework of the Pyramid of Influence.
[ZH] 現在是處於一個調節的狀態,它是可以聽人講話,然後進行理性思考和選擇的
[ZH] 那哪一個神經系統現在是屬於失調的狀態
[ZH] 它是在啟動本能生存機制
[ZH] 所以我們就不能用單一技巧去硬套在所有孩子的隨時的狀態下
[ZH] 而是去辨識出當下眼前孩子是屬於哪一個狀態
[ZH] 然後採取相應的介入
[ZH] 在決定要採取什麼樣的對應的時候,我們要先有能力可以去判斷對方透露出來的這個說法,
[ZH] 因為我們當下其實常有最有奇妙的時間
[ZH] 比如說今天有兩個學生在教室裡面
[ZH] 有一個人他講話很大聲然後講話的時候揮動他的雙手
[ZH] 另外一個人只是安靜的坐在這個椅子上面
[ZH] 那你可能會覺得現在出狀況應該是第一個
[ZH] 那第二個應該沒什麼事情
[ZH] 但是你如果仔細去解讀就是這兩個學生散發出來的生理訊號
[ZH] 也許其實會得到完全相反的觀察
[ZH] 就是也許其實第二個看似平靜的學生他才是目前有狀況的一位
[ZH] A regulated young person is fairly easy to spot.
[EN]  Breathing is steady, voices at normal pitch and pace, eye contact comes and goes naturally.
[EN]  They can follow a conversation, answer a question, and change their mind if you give them a good reason to.
[EN]  A rising state looks different, and it's often the state we miss because it doesn't look dramatic yet.
[EN]  Watch for faster, shallower breathing, a voice that gets louder, faster, or flatter,
[EN]  Fidgeting, pacing and sudden stillness
[ZH] 第一個如果是在一個很平衡調節的狀態下
[ZH] 通常這個人的呼吸他會是很平穩的
[ZH] 語調節奏是正常的
[ZH] 然後有自然的眼神接觸
[ZH] 然後他的思考方式是具有彈性的
[ZH] 在合理的狀況的脈絡下,它是可以轉換話題的
[EN*]  The second one is the mood of the mood of the mood, rising.
[EN*]  The breath of the mood will be faster, and the mood will be faster.
[EN*]  The mood will be slow, or the response will be slow, or then the response will be slow.
[EN*]  And then the eye will be surprised.
[EN*]  An activated state is usually loud enough that no one misses it.
[EN*]  Raised voice, aggressive posture, refusing every instruction.
[EN*]  But I want to add caution here that we'll return to in a moment.
[EN*]  Activation does not always look loud. Sometimes it looks like nothing at all.
[ZH] 那第三個層級已經是一個 activated的狀態
[ZH] 那他可能會斷然拒絕你的指令
[ZH] 然後跟你對峙、逼近等等
[ZH] 那要這邊注意的是
[ZH] 越大聲不代表他就是越激動的狀態
[ZH] 有的時候一個人可以是非常激動的狀態
[ZH] 但是他的發出的聲音沒有到那麼大
[ZH] 所以不能完全用聲音的音量來決定
[EN*]  This is especially true in a busy classroom or a crowded family dinner, where it is tempting to respond to the loudest thing happening rather than the young person who actually needs our help the most.
[EN]  A child arising quietly in the corner will lose that competition for attention every time unless we are deliberately looking for the quiet signs and not only the loud ones.
[EN]  For now, the discipline I want you to practice is simple.
[EN]  Before you decide what to say, spend three seconds reading the body in front of you, breathing, voice, posture, eye contact.
[ZH] 這三分鐘 read
[ZH] 會 tell you more than the word being said
[ZH] 它會 tell you which tier
[ZH] 所以有的時候發生在吵雜的教室或是家庭
[ZH] 你不會注意到一個成員坐在安靜的角落
[ZH] 但是他其實是屬於一個情緒生活的狀態
[ZH] 這都是需要刻意觀察和留心的
[ZH] 所以下次在決定要說什麼話之前
[ZH] 請花三秒鐘觀察對方的這個生理訊號
[ZH] 觀察他的呼吸眼神還有這個語調的節奏
[ZH] 那也許你就可以做出判斷
[ZH] 這個一樣是一個觀察的技巧,技巧都是需要練習的,所以我們表現最好的員工其實不是說他接受最多訓練,而是他可以最常去練習這些學到的技巧
[ZH] 我再想做一個更多的証言,因為我們是改變成一個動態。
[ZH] 我們很多人都會認為一個動態的動態是一個東西。
[ZH] 在練習中,它會顯示三種不同的東西,只有一個是很大聲。
[ZH] 我們在講到最激動的那個activated的狀態的時候,其實是有不一樣的呈現方式,我翻成三種,但只有一種是會出現很大的聲音的。
[EN*]  Fight looks like we expect, yelling, throwing, squaring up, refusing outright.
[EN*]  It's the easiest state to recognize because it announces itself.
[EN*]  The most emotional state is activated state. It has three types of display. The first is fight, which is a combat mode. This is the best to recognize. We expect that the emotional state will be a big sound. It will be a big sound. For example, the child is screaming, or the child is not talking to you. It will be a big sound, so you will feel it is a good to recognize.
[ZH] 在大吼大叫,摔東西,或是拒絕跟你講話
[ZH] 那因為他會發出很大的聲音,所以你會覺得這是很好辨認的
[EN*]  It's because it's not safe, and we want to create a matter of science.
[EN*]  Freeze is the one we miss most often, and it may be the most important of the three.
[EN*]  Freeze looks like stillness, silence, a flat expression, no eye contact, something even small, close-lipped, smile, and reads as calm or as defines.
[ZH] 沒有眼影,甚至小一點,近臉笑,寫得更靜,或是正確的。
[ZH] 因為他不太會發出聲音,所以大人會以為他現場是還好的狀態
[ZH] 我想說為什麼被誤會的狀況下,因為他不太會發出聲音,所以大人會以為他現場是還好的狀態
[ZH] 我想說為什麼被誤會的狀態,因為他不太會發出聲音,所以大人會以為他現場是還好的狀態
[ZH] 被誤會的狀況下其實也是很不好發覺跟處理的
[ZH] 因為當一個孩子,他去接觸另外一個正在當機 freeze中的孩子
[EN*]  This matters especially for the neurodivergent young people many of us work with.
[EN*]  A student with autism who goes still and quiet during a sensory overload is not being defiant.
[EN*]  A student with ADHD who suddenly cannot answer a simple question is not stalling.
[EN*]  In both cases, the central nervous system has simply reached its limit,
[EN*]  and it is showing us the only way it has left.
[EN*]  Here's a mistake I want you to avoid, because I have made it myself.
[EN*]  Reading a frozen young person is compliant, or reading them is defiant,
[EN*]  when their nervous system is as activated as the one who is shouting across the room.
[EN*]  A quiet room is not always a calm room.
[ZH] 所以我會講說一句話
[ZH] 一個安靜的房間不代表是一個平靜的房間
[EN]  The tier we reach for is the same, but how we approach the young person in front of us looks different depending on which one we're looking at.
[EN]  Get the distinction wrong and we either push a frozen child into further shutdown or mistake a fleeing child for one who simply does not care.
[EN]  Hold on to this idea. We'll come back to it directly later because it changes how we read some of the hardest moments we face.
[EN]  I'd rather have you leave today, be able to name all three of these accurately, than be able to recite all six tiers of the Pyramid of Influence from memory.
[ZH] 我們會否判斷瞭解決定的問題。
[ZH] 哭只能夠用來看它們的瘋狀態。
[ZH] 我們需要給他耐心,還有我們自身的安靜陪伴,總之就是我們要去學會辨識孩子發出的身體訊號,再來決定我們要給予怎麼樣的回應言語內容,那就是對應到我們剛才一開始講的金字塔。
[ZH] 我們現在先從金字塔最底層開始看
[ZH] 它叫做Heart and Peace
[ZH] 那其實我們之前有給過它另外一個名字
[ZH] 叫做The Telos韋魯令
[ZH] 就是Telos的內在同在狀態
[ZH] 那如果今天這個大人自身情緒失控
[ZH] 那你就不可能要求一個青少年
[ZH] 跟你一起調節他的情緒
[ZH] 就是會跟你一起失控
[ZH] 所以我們在開口講出任何話之前
[ZH] 我們自身的平靜其實就是
[ZH] 第一個最重要的介入方式
[ZH] 我們再次說這就是Taflon的概念, 敬、 敬、 敬、 敬、 敬、 敬、 讓我們無法合作。 如果這就是我們最好的專案, 我們還是在最好的專案的專案。 大家記得我之前講的Taflon觀念, 就是不沾鍋的那個平臺。
[EN*]  If this is the only tier we ever get right, we're still ahead of where most well-meaning adults start.
[EN*]  Let me make this concrete.
[EN*]  A few months ago, one of our staff members walked into the milieu after a genuinely hard morning of his own.
[EN]  Fifteen minutes later, one of the students refused a simple request to put a book away.
[EN]  Time for group, and that student began to raise his voice.
[EN]  The old instinct is to match that energy, raise your own voice, repeat the instruction more firmly, hold the line.
[EN]  I've done it myself, and I understand exactly why it feels necessary in the moment.
[EN]  Instead, our staff member did something quieter. He lowered his voice. He slowed his own breathing. He said only, I hear you. Let's figure this out together. And then he waited.
[ZH] 那給大家一個例項,就是前陣子有一個學生在面對要轉換空間場景的時候
[ZH] 就只是請他把書收起來,準備要去下一個團體課
[ZH] 那那個時候他就是不知道為什麼他的情緒就升高,然後他就是講話就變得很大聲
[EN*]  Within about 30 seconds, the student's voice dropped to match his.
[EN]  I think about what would have happened if he matched the energy instead.
[EN]  In my experience, that path almost always ends the same way.
[EN]  Rigidity, a longer struggle, a bigger consequence, and two people who feel worse than when it all started.
[EN]  That is the hard piece in practice.
[EN]  Our calm was the intervention before a single strategy from any other tier was ever needed.
[EN]  and notice what it costs, nothing but a few seconds and our own regulation.
[ZH] 小的時刻都在我們的節目中有幾個次,最多的都會不會聽到,但這就是真正的工作,在影響的影響。
[ZH] 這個孩子變得更固執,還是不願意收屬
[ZH] 所以其實告訴我們說,我們的情緒平靜是很重要的
[ZH] 所以我們會把它揮在金字塔的最底層
[ZH] 它在運用任何其他策略前就會有發揮了關鍵作用
[ZH] 那看看這個例子裡面,它花費的成本是什麼
[ZH] 其實也就是我們的工作人員花了幾秒鐘
[ZH] 自我調節自己的呼吸跟情緒而已
[ZH] 第2層是建立關係,因為情感連結可以創造實質的影響力,而影響力而非再次遭遇,而再次遭遇,再次遭遇其中一層是建立關係的情感,
[ZH] 因為情感連結可以創造實質的影響力,而影響力而非強迫他們的順從,才是帶來
[ZH] 長期改變的真正動力
[ZH] 尤其是我們有很多孩子
[ZH] 他其實總是受到大人的糾正和指責
[ZH] 那今天如果他可以感覺到他被理解、被看見
[ZH] 這樣子的關係才是真的有意義的
[ZH] 我們使用什麼叫做誠心的技術
[EN*]  and enjoy. Alongside that, we listen, affirm, and validate while still holding firm, respectful
[EN*]  boundaries. In short, we show we care before we ask for change. I've never once seen an
[EN*]  adolescent make lasting change for someone they did not trust.
[ZH] 有複數同理,以及去仿效同在,還有客觀免數行為,還有單純的享受相處的時光,各五個。
[EN]  guarded arms crossed one word and answers every attempt at conversation redirected back to us with
[EN]  flat why do you care for the first several weeks our team didn't push we used pride we praised what
[EN]  what we could with genuine praise, reflected back what he said instead of correcting it,
[EN]  describe what we noticed instead of judging it, and we showed up consistently whether he engaged or not.
[ZH] 特別是我們面對的是之前總是對大人感到失望的這樣的孩子
[ZH] 比如說我們前陣子有一個剛轉來的學生
[ZH] 他的防衛心就很重
[ZH] 他常常就是對我們工作人員都很冷漠
[ZH] 然後我們每次跟他對話他都會回說該你們的事
[ZH] 然後我們的團隊連續幾週也沒有強推要求他
[ZH] 就只是用這個快的技巧要陪伴與他同在
[ZH] 那就是連續的幾週呢,就是看似好像都沒什麼進展,可是就是我們還是持續運用就是這些事情。
[ZH] 這些技巧陪伴他與他同在
[ZH] 那可是有一天忽然
[ZH] 這個孩子他就主動問我們的工作人員
[ZH] 你明天還會不會來帶這個團體這樣子
[ZH] 那我們聽到那個孩子主動我們說明天還不會來帶他
[ZH] 其實這一句主動的提問就象徵著關係是建立了
[ZH] 那關係建立好以後
[ZH] 那後續要有任何技能傳授給他都會有地方可以著入
[ZH] 所以這一層是很重要的
[ZH] 它在這一層經濟場上面的那些層次都必須要以這一層為基礎
[ZH] 那我必須跟大家誠實的說
[ZH] 那它的培養是需要時間的
[ZH] 那就是可能會比我們希望的它要慢很多
[ZH] 那因為一起直接命令就是學生去順從你
[ZH] 就是關係的建立是很花時間的
[ZH] 第三層是一種你已經知道了
[ZH] 所以我會離開這段階段,這就是我們昨天過程中的訓練方式。
[ZH] 第三層就是我們早上花了整個演講探討的手段,因為早上我講得很詳細,上這個層級我就會先跳過。
[ZH] 第四個層級是聽到學習,我們會聽到,真心,不不不不,我們會用一項鍵,我們會用一項鍵,我們會用一項鍵,我們會用一項鍵,我們會用一項鍵,這是一個實際的訊息,讓人的轉動,和年輕人,會用一項鍵,讓人的經常會用一項鍵。
[ZH] 那第四個層級是去傾聽他
[ZH] 然後以得到就是理解
[ZH] 那我們在教這個孩子之前
[ZH] 我們要先學會傾聽他
[ZH] 而且你傾聽他的這個態度
[ZH] 是要真正對他感到好奇
[ZH] 也不是很憤怒的狀態
[ZH] 那我們之前有講到talking stick
[ZH] 就是發言棒這個工具
[ZH] 那這個工具呢
[ZH] 提供一個很明確的視覺提醒
[ZH] 讓本來有溝通困難的年輕人知道說現在輪到誰講話了,然後也會無量問問題,讓他們更有同意。
[ZH] 我們請開關的問題,我們確定感受到情感前提出,我們尋找方法,讓人們尋找方法,而在原則,而在罵罵。
[ZH] 這瓶子請我們醫生和護理人士問一件難的問題,我們真的不認識答案,但願意找到。
[ZH] 這個層級的話也是鼓勵大家要提出開放性的問題
[ZH] 那在處理行為問題本身要先去接納情緒
[ZH] 然後是建立在一個雙贏的局面上
[ZH] 不是你不聽我的就處罰你這樣子
[ZH] 那最後一個什麼事
[ZH] 概度應該是我還不瞭解你
[EN]  I don't know the question, but I really want to know the question.
[EN]  Here's what Listen and Learn looks like when it's working.
[EN]  A student comes to staff curious about a peer, insisting he wants that peer to move into
[EN]  a different group.
[EN]  The easy response would have been to correct the tone, or simply just say no.
[EN]  Instead, the staff picked up the talking stick, sat down and asked one question.
[EN]  me what happened from the beginning.
[ZH] 舉個例子,也是在我們機構裡面有一個同學他很生氣,然後要求我們的工作人員把其中一個同組的同學要調走,他不想拿一組的,那我們生活陪伴師就拿起發言報道他講說,欸,可不可以從頭告訴我發生了什麼事情。
[ZH] 發生的事實在不是關於公司,是因為男生覺得他在午飯時離開,他一直被禁止,他還要到執行的程式。我們知道這個,這個診斥並不是關於公司,是關於他幫助名的那種,並給他詳細語,並且要求他被禁止,而要求他被禁止,而要求他被禁止。
[ZH] 經過梳理後,我們才發現真正的起因是因為這個同學在中午吃飯的時候感覺到被排擠,然後他就觸發了他以前甚至來到我們機構之前就有了一個被排擠的創傷經驗,所以他其實也不是真的很討厭那個同學。所以有的時候我們就是要經過梳理才可以找到問題的真正主因。
[EN*]  The complaint about the peer was real, but it was not the actual problem.
[EN*]  and a faster response would have solved the wrong thing.
[EN*]  That is the whole point of this tier.
[EN*]  Behavior is communication,
[ZH]  It also changed how the staff responded to them going forward.
[ZH] 我們知道他所意見的意思,我們開始發現他在恨後的事件中,他也不是真的討厭他同學,並不是問題的所在。
[ZH] 如果我們急著因為他有這樣的行為和抱怨去處理的話,我們可能就處理錯事情了。
[ZH] 他真正的這個其實想要講的話是他以前被排解的這個創傷經驗
[ZH] 所以就是我們必須要很認真的去聽所有行為背後的訊息
[ZH] 第五個層級是教導和諮詢,在這個階段我們就從單純傾聽脈向主動教導他們。
[ZH] 但是角色是一個consultant,是一個顧問,是一個諮詢者,而不是在指揮他們。
[ZH] 在這個層級我們要做的是共同解決問題,提供他們選項,然後直接傳授他們生活技能,不是告訴他們什麼是對的什麼是錯的。
[ZH] 所以這一層的目的是要建立自我倡導能力,這項能力是很重要的,就是希望可以長久陪伴孩子。
[ZH] 設計 consult is where a lot of well-meaning adults slide back into lecturing so let me show you the difference
[EN]  The staff sat with them and asked, what are your options here? Not, here's what you're going to do.
[ZH] 舉個例子,我們機構裡面有一個學生,他連續四周都沒有好好教作業
[ZH] 然後我們的生活陪伴師也沒有對他說教
[ZH] 而是問他說,我們在這邊有哪一些選項,哪一些事情是你覺得做可以改善的
[ZH] 後來這個學生想出了三個解決方法
[ZH] 然後最後採納了其中一個就是在她的那個書的活頁夾貼上檢查清單
[ZH] 然後每天睡前去檢查有完成就打勾
[ZH] 那這個方法之所以有效
[ZH] 不是說我們叫她這麼做
[ZH] 而是因為這是她自己想出來的計劃
[ZH] 她是在親自解決自己的問題
[ZH] 那是這個專案的做正在做正在做什麼
[ZH] 建立自己的監視監視著我們
[ZH] 我們不會坐在他接近10年
[ZH] 提醒他自己的工作
[ZH] 這就是我們剛剛講的這層阻止是要建立自我倡導能力,自我倡導能力,因為我們十年後不可能還在陪著孩子做作業,我們希望這個技巧是超越貼上檢查清單這個動作的意義本色。
[ZH] 他希望這個技巧是可以陪著他長長久久的
[ZH] 或是叫警察、警察、警察。這一直跟E-Briefing的關聯和建立。
[ZH] 自己危險或是極端的狀況的時候才使用
[ZH] 比如說你可能會需要更換陪伴人員
[ZH] 或是你要排除在圍觀的群眾
[EN*]  And we need to do a debriefing every time we need to make a debriefing.
[EN*]  Just to see what happens next to us and see what happens next to us.
[EN*]  And we need to strengthen our safety.
[EN*]  Before we move on, I want to spend a moment on the moment none of us look forward to.
[EN*]  When protecting correct stops being hypothetical, and a student, a client, or your own child becomes physically aggressive.
[EN]  The good news is that most of us, most of what keeps a moment like that from becoming a crisis is still verbal, not physical.
[EN]  This is where Crisis Regents Institute's CPI or de-escalation model is worth knowing, whether or not you've been through their training.
[ZH] 假如說你經濟的暗主或是你的小孩變得很暴力,就是會想要打人
[ZH] 好訊息是,我們最多的,一切都會保持危機的事件,而不是實際的事件
[EN*]  This is where the Crisis Prevention Institute or CPI, De-escalation Model, is worth knowing whether or not you've been through their training.
[EN*]  A few of their core techniques, be empathetic, non-judgmental.
[EN*]  The feeling is real, even if the behavior isn't okay.
[EN*]  Respect personal space and watch your own positioning, especially when things feel unpredictable.
[EN]  Use non-threatening body language.
[EN]  Your tone, your posture, say more than your words do.
[EN]  Keep your own emotional brain in check,
[EN]  because your calm is what makes de-escalation impossible at all.
[EN]  Don't engage in challenging questions.
[EN]  Redirect back to the issue, not the argument.
[EN]  Set limits that are simple, respectful, and few,
[EN]  and allow silence and times.
[EN]  A few extra seconds to decide is often the difference between compliance and explosion.
[ZH] Is often the difference between compliance and explosion
[ZH] 好 那其實剛才講師講的這些內容
[ZH] 在同影片上面都有了
[ZH] 就很快地帶過
[ZH] 就是其實降溫心法就是有保持同理
[ZH] 尊重個人肢體空間
[ZH] 還有使用不具威脅的肢體語言
[ZH] 控制大人自身的腦部情緒
[ZH] 還有不捲入挑釁的爭辯
[ZH] 然後設定、間短、尊重的界線
[ZH] 還有給予安靜程度的時間
[ZH] 就是同一篇上面寫的這些
[ZH]  let me escape to the next slide
[ZH]  picture a teacher's version
[EN*]  Okay.
[EN*]  Picture a teacher's version.
[EN*]  A student flips his desk, throws a book, and squares up towards a classmate.
[EN*]  That state is danger to others.
[EN*]  The response, signal for backup right away.
[EN*]  An app, a radio, a student sent to the office,
[EN*]  clearing the surrounding students calmly.
[EN*]  Keep a level voice.
[EN*]  Hand off to the administrator once they arrive and debrief afterwards.
[EN*]  If there are some problems in the school, you may be angry and upset the table, and then throw the table, and then kill the students, and then kill the students.
[EN*]  The teachers can be able to send the information to the students, to keep the students safe and to report the staff.
[EN*]  Picture a parent's version. Your teenager slams the door, punches the wall, and says she wants to hurt herself. That's not a tantrum, that's a safety crisis. The response, get the other children out of the room. Keep your own voice and body calm. Call your partner or another trusted adult. And if there's a real risk, call emergency services. That is exactly the moment they call Exist for.
[ZH] that's a safety crisis
[ZH] the response
[ZH] get the other children out of the room
[ZH] 保持你自己的聲音和身體安靜。
[ZH] 叫你的相伴或其他信任的孩子。
[ZH] 如果有個真正的危險,叫緊急支援。
[ZH] 那是正當時,他們在叫緊急支援。
[ZH] 家長的版本或是你的小孩可能摔門、摧牆、想要自傷。
[ZH] 那這次安全危機就不是單純發脾氣而已。
[ZH] 所以這項聯益措施可以是帶著其他的孩子離開,
[ZH] 保持語氣、肢體冷靜,打電話給你另一半,
[ZH] 或是撥打緊急服務的電話
[ZH] 我掉到那次醫生的位置
[ZH] 全部都在同一層,保護和正確
[ZH] 完全不同的房間
[ZH] 什麼都保護是整個系統
[ZH] 看這個系統,回應特別的時間
[ZH] 並不只保護它
[ZH] 所以其實這上面三個案例
[ZH] 都是在第六個層級
[ZH] 就是最高層級
[ZH] Protagon Correct
[ZH] 就是請大家要辨認出正確的狀態
[ZH] 然後選出適當的回應
[ZH] 當我們混合我們的瘋狀在臉上的瘋狀態 rather than surface behavior,
[ZH] 我們就停止失去一個腦瘋狀系統的危機,讓一個年輕人直接被解決了。
[ZH] 所以,這個精神打核心就告訴我們要將層級配對到生理生心的狀態。
[ZH] 外在的行為本身沒有辦法告訴我們要有哪一個層級。
[ZH] 我們必須要實際解析的是
[ZH] 底層的神經系統生理狀態才是關鍵
[ZH] 比如說同樣是極度交感神經活化的狀態
[ZH] 就是 activate 最高的那個層次
[ZH] 它可能呈現的會是我們剛剛講到有三種
[ZH] 就是 fight, flight 和 freeze
[ZH] 看起來呈現的方式都很不一樣
[ZH] 但是你要是認識這個結構以後
[ZH] 你就會知道說
[ZH] 其實他們可能都已經是情緒很高漲的狀態下了
[ZH] 所以我要去辨認出來
[ZH] 那假設我們要怎麼看這個金字塔呢
[ZH] 當你眼前這個海域它是出現一個
[ZH] low regulated 的情緒狀態的話
[ZH] 我們就可以用和平之心
[ZH] 建立關係還有 processing approach 來面對
[ZH] 如果它是 rising 一個中階的情緒狀態的話
[ZH] 我們就可以一樣用 processing approach
[ZH] 然後呢 請聽來個理解
[ZH] 那如果它今天是已經到一個
[ZH] 這個 high climate 的狀態的話
[ZH] 的狀態的話,我們就需要用到第六個層級,就是比較極端的狀況下,protect and correct,那同樣一個孩子他可能一個下午會經歷不同的層級。
[ZH] 好,那最後給大家整理三個重點,第一個,生理狀態永遠是優先的叛讀,
[ZH] 我們要先判斷神經系統狀態,再決定要哪個層次來回應,第二個是固著僵化是一個警訊,他不是故意要作對,因為這個freeze還有這個暴衝其實都是神經超載根源的一個呈現方式。
[ZH] 最後一個金字塔頂層的保護和修正,他應該是要應付在特殊狀況,就是危機的狀況,不應該讓他成為日常常態,他佔金字塔最小一塊是有原因的,我們大部分的工作應該在底層完成,不要讓他上升到金字塔最上層
[ZH] 我希望你們一最後一想,在我的三個講題上,我們談到解決於小學,教學,現在的現在的影響,這些想法不能分別,解決於我們為何,技術開展指教我們,和我們所教的關係,和相關的關係,和相關的關係,是一種成功的。
[ZH] 第一場演講是教大家如何理解孩子,第二場演講是教大家要教孩子什麼東西,第三場演講就是要如何去影響孩子,那理解孩子就會知道他們背後發生的原因,然後教導孩子的話要知道要教導他們什麼事情,什麼技能,那如何影響孩子的話就是要他們建立關係然後選擇應對的方式
[ZH] 每一個困難的交流變成一個機會
[ZH] 每一刻的失調會變成一個機會
[ZH] 遇到一個年輕人在哪裡
[ZH] 而是希望在哪裡
[ZH] 每一個交流的交流變成一個機會
[ZH] 變成一個機會改變的生活
[EN*]  I hope the Pyramid of Influence gives you one more framework that you can adapt within your own program, schools, clinics, and families.
[EN*]  Thank you.
[ZH] 都還有一個新的參考架構
[ZH] 那這三個分享他們是相處相成的
[ZH] 謝謝大家
[ZH] 好